now that everything's busy and bustling
again it's kind of like I've realized
there are some places I don't want to go
to as much anymore like I like
yeah I mean I haven't been there but one
place
one one place I have been to is a shibia
oh yeah and I I
forgotten how busy it gets right because
it's like because I remember when I when
I was a tourist visiting here I was like
should be a such a cool [ __ ] area you
know it's got so many bars and it's just
busy in Boston just because you know
there's better areas now yeah yeah and
like now as a local it was still all
right to go to when it like when you
know the country was closed because you
had space and you had Comfort but I
remember like this past like two weeks
I'd been to like shibia three times and
like after the first time I'm like I
[ __ ] hate people I I think I hate
people right now I just like
yeah no no I've noticed that it's like I
I went to Shibuya last week and like it
was like 2 p.m on a Thursday yeah and I
remember like during the quarantine it
was like you know there'd still be
people of course because it's Tokyo
right but you know it's like pretty
quiet you know considering that I I also
experienced Shibuya before the pandemic
as well and now I went back and I'm like
I can't see the road
like I'm standing oh you get to [ __ ]
uh yeah you get to the Cross it's like
it's like 2PM on a Thursday there's like
400 people on this side of the road
another 400 on the other side like where
are you all from where where were you
guys during the pandemic
well so combined with the yeah and then
combined with the tourists yeah
obviously tourists right now yeah
they're saying Japanese people now are
way more comfortable going out yeah yeah
so that's been going up yeah dude if you
come to Tokyo as a tourist and there's
more than like four of you bro it's so
hard to not like to just turn up to
restaurants and stuff now you have to
book yeah and it sucks because some of
them you have to call up in Japanese
yeah so if you don't have that one
friend who can do that for you you're
pretty much just limited to where you
can it does suck if you don't have
someone or know someone who's Japanese
or are able to speak Japanese you get
very limited with options in terms of
yeah you don't realize you're limited
right yeah I mean I mean yeah actually I
just because I realized this because uh
when I was when I was walking to the uh
bar that we where I was meeting some
people in in Shibuya uh I remember
looking around uh no it wasn't shibia
sorry it was uh where did I go again I
think I think it was like near Shinjuku
right uh so I was meeting I was meeting
a friend at the bar and I remember
walking it was like very very bustling
and I remember there was one restaurant
there was one restaurant you know you
normally see Japanese people lining up
for a restaurant right and you have to
like wait outside and stuff like that so
this one restaurant was like people were
lining up for this one restaurant but it
wasn't Japanese people it was all
foreigners and I looked up and it was
itchy Ron Ramen
and I was like no no no no no
pains me every time I see it I've never
lined up for it I refused it is not
lineup worthy I was like clearly not
trash days for yours you know clear
clearly this is the one thing we've
warned you guys again so I can't start
it right past those people with
confidence knowing fully well none of
them will turn around
is a very popular uh Ramen chain in
Japan it's very popular with tourists
but you can get each one outside of
Japan as well so you can what's the
point okay do that I like Ichiro all
right is it is it the best ramen ever no
would I line up for it certainly hold on
I think it tastes good though
I like because you can make it spicy
that's about it yeah it's a five it's
it's fine it's a five out of ten it
ain't a ten it is yeah it's okay I mean
to be fair it is hard to find good ramen
places because as well people on reviews
for some reason Japan are super [ __ ]
brutal with Ramen they yeah yeah yeah it
is hard to find a Ramen place above 4.2
like I don't think I've seen one for a
very long time well it's most of them
are like 3.8 yeah but it's also because
like again like there's this kind of
subculture in Japan of like Ramen
elitists as I like to call them where
they're just like they got their job or
just hobbies to just like any time they
have free they go to a [ __ ] new Ramen
place they try it out and then they just
tear that [ __ ] out right yeah and it's
of course with ramen places you're not
gonna find that one place that everyone
unanimously likes you know obviously
with Ramen some people like to show you
some people like the Miso some yeah the
salt more yeah and it's so hard to
dictate so it's like just go in just
like don't even look at reviews in my
opinion with ROM unless it's like a two
yeah then obviously don't go in there
but I have the uh sort of opposite story
to what you mentioned you're in um
okayama station which is kind of like
I'm sorry yeah how do you even describe
it's a big Transit Hub yeah um for
shinkansen's a lot of trains stop there
and uh that's why we were there we were
like well let's get let's get dinner so
we're looking around the station and we
were gonna go outside saw those giant
restaurant massive right huge could
probably fit like
100 people yeah pretty big right
no one in it no one everything else was
like pretty full yeah there was like
nobody in this restaurant
and we will flash this place twice and
later on we walked past again like two
hours later and there's one elderly
couple sitting in there eating right so
and this thing looked pristine like I if
I didn't know what it was I would have
walked in there and gladly have sat down
and been like this is a pretty really
nice place yeah what do you think the
food they served was
it's a Japanese dish
Japanese what do you think is a Japanese
dish that some not even like some
Japanese people want to eat
and they had a whole giant ass
restaurant for it
thing think about an obscure type of
dish that that's obscure no well I I
mean I haven't seen it often yeah um it
was intestinal Hot Pot what's there
what's up
and I was just like that's like because
she's like no we're absolutely not going
in there so yeah it's just intestinal
Hot Pot I actually like that okay would
you would you like but I would not I
would never be your first choice it
wouldn't be my first choice and I would
be suss as [ __ ] if I saw a multinari
place that big it was huge with no one
in it it was it was so big for like what
I thought was a even for Japanese
standards it's like you rarely hear
Japanese people talk about this being
their favorite type of food right like
there's a lot of other stuff I would I
would look at that and my first reaction
would be someone's died in that
restaurant someone has died from like
badly like preserved you know food bad
dishes
yeah yeah yeah so yeah it's just
intestinal hot pot yeah
um and it's actually really nice during
the winter but it's uh but but also
carry out though would you ever choose
it over a normal Japanese Hot Pot no no
I get it I get it yeah it's like that's
like a once a year thing for me yeah if
that it was just odd how I it's I don't
have an issue with it existing and being
intestinal Hot Pot I'm like oh what the
intestines it's so gross I know they do
that normally I was just surprised at
how large this restaurant was dedicated
to that because that's quite rare yeah
because normally it's like they're a hot
pot dedicated that have that maybe have
more it's one of the items but like only
multiple best food ever oh my God
okay I was in okayama
she said it's the best food ever [ __ ]
right off dude no listen I've had I've
had I've had the the cow intestine stuff
yeah at Chinese hot pot it's fine I
wasn't I I'm not like a fussy eater I
feel like I refuse to eat it I just
think that like there are a lot of
people who like it yeah very easy like
people who are like that's my face yeah
there are some certain foods that I'm
fine with eating
it's not the chicken feet restaurant you
know what I mean like can we just can we
just have a chicken restaurant that also
has chicken feed why are we specializing
in this why is it also specialized in
like the one thing where it's like yeah
yeah
and you know it's yeah but it's a
polarizing and also I wouldn't like it's
like going to a restaurant that's like
oh we specialize in celery it's like uh
not sure if I I like celery I don't know
if this is just myself yeah there's
other dishes that I would like I don't
know so we just went to a Yakitori place
in the end yeah it was fine
you can get more to there as well if you
wanted yeah yeah it's fine that's really
weird yeah I don't know I'm curious
actually no you know what I shouldn't
get the Curiosity get the best of me
because I'm probably gonna get food
poisoning and then Chris wanted to go to
an Irish Pub we're into an Irish Pub
inside really it was so awkward but
whenever you want to go to an Irish bar
no you just I don't know you want a
proper drink okay she said they serve
pints British pints British Pines oh
okay
[Music]
Chris any amount of money stay in that
restaurant I think Christian would stab
me rather than going how did you get
food poisoning again
listen I'm sure it's safe I'm sure it's
fine it's just I was because it looked
brand new really like nice really clean
really like well kept really nice
branding lots of spaces I was just kind
of like
maybe it's like Ultra expensive it might
be again if you're Ultra expensive
matsanabe which seems like a very Niche
food why would you be in a train station
that's true that's normally trained like
not to there's some good places to eat
in train stations Japan but it's
normally like the very yeah very
affordable very middle tier kind of fast
because a lot of the time people are in
a hurry right so it's never like really
classy high-end fancy places so you feel
like if you're going for that kind of
Market you kind of would maybe Market
towards yeah yeah that's true I don't
know and again it made sense that the
only people I saw in there were one
couple that was very elderly one elderly
couple that's it
empty I've never met young Japanese
people who are like my favorite food's
monster number mailing mailing doesn't
no she said it's nice I bet she's
[ __ ] she's supposed to be contrarian
no she says she said it's the best food
in Fukuoka [ __ ] off that's what she just
said in in so there's a place in uh
Miyazaki which has the best beef in
Japan that is way better I'll take that
thank you very much